hello and welcome to data tab now I will
show you how I can analyze your data in
an easy and uncomplicated way directly
online with data tab to do this go to
datadab.net and click on the online
statistics calculator then you choose
empty table and insert your own data
into this table and now the variables
that you want to analyze appear here
below of course you can also just import
an Excel file with your data it is
important to make sure that the names of
your variables are listed in the first
row in these steps you will find the
methods you need to analyze your data in
the first step you can analyze your data
descriptively for example you can
display the mean value or the standard
deviation you can also create frequency
tables and cross steps
in that tab you can now perform a
variety of hypotheses tests data tab
helps you to find the right test an
example in your survey you asked men and
women about their salary and now you
want to know whether men and women
differ in terms of salary to find out
you select the variables salary and
gender data that knows which test is
suitable for your question and suggests
the t-test for independent samples
if the assumptions for the t-test for
independent samples are not met you can
calculate a non-parametric test the man
with new test
of course you can also calculate many
other hypotheses tests of data tab for
example if you click on the nominal
variable with more than two
characteristics an analysis of variance
is automatically performed that means
depending on which variables you select
data tab makes you a suggestion for a
suitable test you can change the scale
level of the variables here what other
methods are available of course with
data tab you can also easily calculate
for example a correlation analysis A
regression analysis a principal
component analysis and a class analysis
if you want to know how to do this just
have a look at our tutorials for each
method you can calculate you find
detailed tutorials here which are
explained very simply also feel free to
check out our YouTube channel thanks for
watching and enjoy using data tab